>> SOME OF THE GIRLS
HAD TROUBLE
ADJUSTING TO ROOMMATE RENEE.
>> THERE IS, LIKE,
TONS OF OTHER GIRLS
WHO WOULD DIE TO BE HERE
FOR MODELING.
>> I AM.
>> DON'T GET DEFENSIVE.
>> JASLENE DIDN'T MAKE THE CUT
IN CYCLE 7.
>> (singsong voice) I'M BACK!
>> (laughs)
BUT SHE WAS
A TOUGH ACT TO FOLLOW
AT THE FIRST PHOTO SHOOT.
>> THANK YOU. WELL DONE.
>> AS EVERYONE ELSE
STRUGGLED TO KEEP UP...
>> REALLY BELIEVE IT
FOR THAT SPLIT MOMENT,
REALLY GIVE IT TO ME.
>> KATHLEEN WAS LOST,
AND IT SHOWED IN HER PHOTO.
>> YOU DIDN'T
COMPLETELY UNDERSTAND
THE CONCEPT.
>> I KNOW, RIGHT?
>> AND IN THE END,
SHE WAS THE FIRST GIRL
SENT HOME.
>> BYE, GUYS.
>> 12 GIRLS REMAIN.
WHO WILL BE ELIMINATED TONIGHT?
>> ♪  YOU WANT TO BE ON TOP? ♪
♪ ♪ ♪
>> I MISS KATHLEEN.
(phone ringing)
>> HELLO?
>> How was your day?
>> OH, MY GOD, MOM, THE BOMB.
>> Ah!
>> I CAME ON TOP.
LAST TIME IN PANEL,
MY NAME WAS CALLED FIRST,
AND I WAS SO HAPPY.
>> CONGRATULATIONS.
>> THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THE POSITIVE FEEDBACK
THAT I GOT TODAY
WAS SO GOOD.
>> WELL, THE CAMERA LOVES YOU.
>> IT'S SOMETHING EXTRA SPECIAL.
>> THANK YOU, GUYS, SO MUCH.
I'M FIERCE.
I'M HERE FOR A REASON.
WHEN I'M IN MY OWN ZONE
AND I'M FOCUSED,
THAT'S WHEN I PERFORM THE BEST.
>> AND THEN YOU JUST BACK OFF.
>> (laughs)
(speaking gibberish)
>> I'M PRETTY MUCH
A COUNTRY GIRL,
AND THESE GIRLS ARE JUST--
SOME OF 'EM ARE CRAZY.
>> DETROIT, Y'ALL!
>> WHAT, WHAT?
>> I LIKE TO KEEP TO MYSELF
WHENEVER I'M STRESSED
AND WRITE IN A NOTEBOOK
AND KINDA RELEASE MY FEELINGS
THAT WAY, OR TALK ON THE PHONE
TO MY FAMILY MEMBERS.
>> How you doing?
>> (voice breaks) I'M OKAY.
I JUST REALLY MISS Y'ALL.
>> It'll be all right, okay?
You'll have a good time,
which is--that's the main thing.
Don't forget who you are.
>> (coughs) OKAY, I WILL. I'M...
>> (chuckles)
>> I'LL NEVER FORGET WHO I AM.
I DON'T KNOW IF I FIT IN.
TO ME, I SEEM REALLY DIFFERENT
THAN THE OTHER GIRLS.
BUT I WANNA SEE MYSELF
ON THE COVER OF A MAGAZINE.
I WANNA BE ON THAT CATWALK.
GOOD NIGHT.
>> TYRA MAIL!
"BABIES LEARN HOW TO DO IT.
CAN YOU?
LOVE, TYRA."
>> WALK.
>> OH, WALK!
>> WALK!
♪ ♪ ♪
>> I'M VERY CONFUSED
AT THIS POINT.
I'M LIKE, WHAT ARE WE DOING
AT A HIGH SCHOOL, RIGHT?
(drums playing)
>> I KINDA GLANCE OVER...
MISS J. IS STANDING UP THERE,
AND SO HE HAS ON HIS LITTLE--
WHATEVER KIND OF HAT
THAT WAS.
>> YEAH!
>> WELCOME, LADIES.
I'VE BROUGHT YOU HERE
THIS MORNING
TO SEE THIS WONDERFUL
MARCHING BAND,
WHO IS KNOWN FOR THEIR TIMING,
PRECISION AND CHOREOGRAPHY.
AND SOMETIMES ON THE CATWALK,
YOU NEED TO BE PRECISE.
TODAY I WOULD LIKE TO SEE
JUST HOW PRECISE YOUR WALKS ARE.
SO, GIRLS, GO GET CHANGED.
IT'S TIME FOR CLASS.
♪ ♪ ♪
>> (laughs)
>> I SEE MISS J.--
IT'S WHAT I THINK IS MISS J.--
SO I'M LAUGHING AT THIS POINT.
IT'S JUST KIND OF HYSTERICAL
TO ME.
>> DO YOU KNOW WHY YOU'RE HERE?
>> 'CAUSE WE'RE GONNA WALK.
>> THERE YOU GO, BABY.
AND I WANT YOU
TO WALK THIS WHITE LINE.
GOT IT? HIT IT, MAMA.
TAKE LONGER STEPS, SWEETHEART.
YOU NEED TO HAVE LONGER STEPS.
YEAH, LET HER DO HER THING.
YOU WALK LIKE YOU'RE HOLDING
TWO BAGS OF GROCERIES,
'CAUSE YOUR ARMS STAY LIKE THIS.
OKAY? HIT IT.
AND YOUR RIGHT ARM DOES MOVE,
DOESN'T IT?
'CAUSE IT'S AS STIFF AS A BOARD.
>> I KNEW HE WAS GONNA SAY THAT,
'CAUSE PEOPLE SAY THAT TO ME
ALL THE TIME.
LIKE, IT JUST DOESN'T MOVE.
>> I DON'T KNOW
IF YOU'RE MARCHING OR WALKING.
>> MISS J.--HE SAID THAT
I WALK LIKE I'M "MARTIAN."
I'M DOING GREAT.
>> YOU WALK ON YOUR HEELS A LOT,
I SEE.
>> I'M A LITTLE BIT NERVOUS
AT THIS POINT
IN TRYING TO SHOW J.
THAT I AM FIERCE IN, LIKE,
A LITTLE GIRL'S SCHOOL UNIFORM.
>> YOU NEED
TO TAKE LONGER STEPS.
YOU DO.
COME BACK AND DO IT AGAIN,
JASLENE.
>> I DEFINITELY FOUND
HIS SUGGESTIONS VERY HELPFUL,
BUT, YOU KNOW, THIS IS WHO I AM.
I KNOW I STAND OUT
ONCE I WALK ON THE RUNWAY.
>> THANK YOU.
>> LITTLE MISS CHA-CHA DIVA--
SHE DIDN'T GET, LIKE,
ALL THE PRAISE
THAT SHE WAS EXPECTING TO GET.
(jet engines roaring)
>> GIRLS, TALK ABOUT PRECISION
AND TIMING.
THERE IT IS, RIGHT THERE.
SOMETIMES YOU HAVE TO WORK
IN GROUPS.
SOMETIMES--AND TO DO DOUBLES
OR TRIPLES.
TYRA BANKS HERSELF
HAS DONE A LOT OF SHOWS
WHERE SHE'S HAD TO WALK OUT
WITH ANOTHER GIRL.
SO IT'S ALL ABOUT COORDINATING
WHAT'S GONNA HAPPEN
ON THE CATWALK.
I NEED TO HAVE THREE GIRLS.
I WANT YOU TO WALK
FROM POINT "A" TO POINT "B."
THE GIRL THAT'S IN THE MIDDLE
STAYS RIGHT HERE.
THE OTHER TWO GIRLS
CONTINUE TO WALK,
BUT WHEN YOU BREAK OFF,
YOU'RE GONNA CROSS EACH OTHER,
POSE DOWN THERE.
ON HER WAY BACK,
YOU IN THE CENTER,
START WALKING.
YOU TWO WAIT HERE
FOR HER TO COME BACK.
WHEN SHE COMES BACK,
YOU ALL TAKE OFF.
GOT IT?
>> UH, ALL RIGHT, AND WHAT--
WHAT DOES IT MEAN? LIKE...
(laughs) WHAT SHOULD I DO?
>> HIT IT.
>> HONEY, THAT'S IT.
>> I FEEL LIKE
I DID REALLY GOOD.
I DON'T KNOW ABOUT MY TEAM.
>> I NEED TO HAVE YOU WALKING
BETWEEN THE GIRLS.
>> AND MISS J. HAS ME WALK
WITH JAEL AND NATASHA.
I THINK, PERSONALLY,
THAT IT'S MUCH EASIER
TO WALK IN HEELS BECAUSE
YOU HAVE MORE ELEGANCE, ALMOST.
>> SO THEY CROSS THROUGH HERE.
>> OH.
>> (laughs)
>> (grunts)
WHEN I WATCH THESE GIRLS WALK,
IT'S SO FUNNY TO ME.
>> GIRLS, GO STRAIGHT THROUGH.
♪ ♪ ♪
>> WHOA.
(laughs) I'M SORRY.
I GOT ALL MIXED UP.
>> GO BACK.
>> I REALLY FELT LIKE
I DIDN'T NEED TO PRACTICE.
I'M THE BEST
ONCE I GET OUT THERE.
>> GIRLS,
I THINK I HEAR THE BELL.
(school bell ringing)
(drums playing)
>> CLASS IS OVER.
HEAD TO THE GYM
FOR YOUR FINAL EXAM.
>> HELLO, LADIES.
WELCOME BACK TO HIGH SCHOOL.
MY NAME IS ROY CAMPBELL,
AND I PRODUCE
RUNWAY FASHION SHOWS.
I ALSO HAVE DONE EVENTS
FOR TYRA BANKS,
WHO'S A GOOD FRIEND OF MINE.
I KNOW THAT J. ALEXANDER
GAVE YOU
SOME RUNWAY LESSONS TODAY,
AND I'M HERE TO PUT IT
TO THE TEST.
YOUR CHALLENGE
WILL BE TO COMPETE
IN A LIVE FASHION SHOW,
RIGHT HERE
IN THIS HIGH SCHOOL GYM,
AND THE THEME WILL BE...
(drumroll)
♪ ♪ ♪
>> THE PROM.
>> I'VE NEVER HAD A PROM
BECAUSE WE JUST DON'T HAVE
THIS THING IN, UH, LIKE, RUSSIA.
>> YOU REMEMBER THAT ROUTINE
I SHOWED YOU EARLIER?
>> YES.
>> THAT ROUTINE,
YOU WILL BE DOING TODAY,
HERE AND NOW.
>> WE'RE DOING IT LIVE
IN FRONT OF
THE HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS
FROM THIS SCHOOL.
>> ARE YOU SERIOUS?
WALKING IN FRONT OF
THOSE STUDENTS... OH, MY GOD.
>> AND THE WINNER
OF THIS CHALLENGE
WILL RECEIVE A REALLY BIG PRIZE,
SO I WANNA SEE
YOUR FIERCEST WALK OUT THERE.
>> AND THEY'LL BE
THREE CATEGORIES--
MODERN CONTEMPORARY PROM,
THE '80s...
>> ALL RIGHT!
>> UH-OH!
>> AND THEN YOU'RE GONNA GET
GHETTO FABULOUS.
(cheering and laughing)
>> SEE YOU THEN.
♪ ♪ ♪
>> ALL THIS COVERGIRL MAKEUP--
UM, THEY GOT CUTE SHADOWS.
LIKE, I LOVE THIS ORANGE.
>> JAEL, MAKE SURE YOU GO IN
A LITTLE BIT FASTER
WITH THE, LIKE...
YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN?
>> DO YOU JUST MAKE SURE
YOU DON'T STEP ON MY DRESS?
>> HUH?
>> NATASHA IS TELLING ME
HOW I BETTER NOT MESS UP.
I DON'T KNOW.
IT WAS SO HYSTERICAL TO ME
BECAUSE EVERYONE
IS SO SERIOUS ABOUT, LIKE,
DOING EVERYTHING PERFECT.
>> OKAY, SHOWTIME. CHOP-CHOP.
THERE WILL BE A GREAT PRIZE
FOR THE WINNER
OF THIS CHALLENGE.
LET'S WORK IT OUT, OKAY?
♪ ♪ ♪
>> HEY, HEY, HEY, HEY!
>> (cheering)
>> MY NAME IS ROY CAMPBELL,
AND I'LL BE
YOUR MASTER OF CEREMONIES TODAY
FOR THIS FABULOUS
LIVE FASHION SHOW.
>> I WALK, OR AFTER?
>> IT'S BEFORE.
>> JASLENE IS FULL OF HERSELF.
I REALLY FEEL LIKE
THIS IS DEFINITELY MY TIME
TO SHOW WHAT I'M--
WHAT I HAVE AND WHAT I CAN GIVE.
>> I KNOW I CAN DO IT. YEAH.
>> YEAH, I FORGOT TO CROSS
WHEN I COME BACK.
>> THESE BITCHES CAN TALK ABOUT
THE GAME, BUT CAN YOU
PLAY THE GAME? I HAVE
MY SIGNATURE WALK DOWN PAT.
>>(in Spanish)
>> THE THREE STYLES
FOR THE PROM SHOW ARE
MODERN CONTEMPORARY PROM,
'80s PROM
AND THEN GHETTO FABULOUS.
(laughs)
>> (cheering loudly)
♪ ♪ ♪
>> HEY, HEY, HEY, HEY!
LET'S GET THIS SHOW STARTED.
IT'S PROM TIME.
>> (cheering)
>> WE'RE SHOWING YOU
ELEGANT FASHIONS--
COLUMN GOWNS
THAT HUG EVERY CURVE YOU'VE GOT
AND SOME YOU DIDN'T EVEN KNOW
YOU HAD.
SARAH HAD GREAT POSTURE,
SHE REALLY HAD GREAT FORM,
AND THAT PART HELPED HER ALONG.
THE PROM, THE PROM, THE PROM.
>> RENEE, DIONNE, CASSANDRA.
>> (cheering)
>> I'M A LITTLE BIT NERVOUS
AT THIS POINT IN TRYING TO SHOW
THAT I AM FOCUSED
ON MY CHOREOGRAPHY
AND LOOK GOOD DOING IT.
>> MOVE IT! MOVE IT! MOVE IT!
>> (cheering)
>> RUFFLES, ANYONE?
RUFFLES, FLAPS AND FLOUNCES.
>> I JUST GET
THIS ADRENALINE RUSH.
LIKE, I FEEL LIKE
THERE'S FIRE RUNNING BEHIND ME.
>> SARAH, YOU'RE CROSSING FIRST.
>> WELL, WE'RE GONNA
KEEP IT MOVING,
'CAUSE NOW IT'S THE '80s!
>> (cheering)
>> NATASHA--
SHE WAS NOT REALLY COGNIZANT
OF THE OTHER GIRLS
ON THE RUNWAY.
SHE WAS OFTEN
NOT QUITE WITH THE ROUTINE.
OH, CHECK IT OUT!
>> (cheering)
>> SAMANTHA
HAS GREAT ATTRIBUTES,
AND SHE'S A VERY PRETTY GIRL.
BUT I WOULD LIKE TO SEE SAMANTHA
HAVE A LITTLE MORE ATTITUDE
ON THE RUNWAY.
♪ ♪ ♪
>> COME ON! COME ON, COME ON!
>> (cheering)
>> I FOUND RENEE
TO BE BLAND OR AVERAGE
IN TERMS OF STANDING OUT
FROM THE OTHER GIRLS,
BUT SHE CONNECTED
WITH THE AUDIENCE.
CHECK OUT THE FLOUNCES
AND THE TRAILBLAZING HEMLINES.
>> (cheering)
>> I WAS JUST SORT OF ACTING
AND TRYING TO PLAY THE PARTS
WHILE WALKING
AND TRYING TO HIT MY MARKS.
>> HOOCHIE MAMA, GIRL!
>> IT'S TIME TO REALLY GET LIVE!
CAN WE HEAR
SOMEBODY HOLLA FOR GHETTO?
(brakes screeching)
>> LOOK IT!
>> OH, MAN.
>> (cheering)
>> WHILE WE'RE ON THE CATWALK,
SARAH'S CHEST
DECIDES TO BE EXPOSED
TO ALL THE HIGH SCHOOL CHILDREN
AND THEIR PARENTS.
>> THIS IS SUPPOSED TO BE
A FASHION SHOW,
NOT SEX EDUCATION.
>> I THOUGHT IT WAS
VERY LIBERATING FOR HER,
AND I'M SO PROUD
THAT SHE GOT TO EXPERIENCE THAT
NEXT TO ME.
>> I JUST KEPT ON GOING
BECAUSE, LIKE, I'M NOT GONNA LET
SOMETHING LIKE THAT
RUIN MY RUNWAY WALK.
>> CAN SOMEBODY DO MY HAIR?
>> NOW WILL YOUR MAMA
LET YOU WEAR THESE DRESSES?
>> THAT DRESS NEEDS TO BE BURNED
BECAUSE IT WAS PRETTY MUCH
A SHIRT.
I KNOW THAT I WOULD'VE
NOT BEEN ALLOWED TO GO TO PROM
IN THAT IN ALABAMA.
(brakes screeching)
>> THIS IS
A RUNWAY FASHION SHOW,
NOT THE BUMPING CARS.
WHEN IT CAME DOWN
TO THE ACTUAL ROUTINE,
SOME OF THEM DID VERY POORLY.
SO MANY GIRLS
CRASHED INTO EACH OTHER,
MISSING THEIR ROUTINE,
MISSING THEIR MARKS.
>> BRITTANY, YOU'RE LIVE.
>> OH!
BRITTANY HAS A VERY STRONG
RUNWAY LOOK,
AND SHE REALLY GETS THE CATWALK.
(brakes screeching)
>> OOPS.
IF THAT HAD BEEN A FREEWAY,
THAT'D BE A 5-CAR PILEUP.
JASLENE WAS THE ONE THAT REALLY
DID NOT GET THE CHOREOGRAPHY,
DIDN'T UNDERSTAND
WHERE OTHER GIRLS WAS,
AND DIDN'T SEEM TO CARE EITHER.
YES, OUR GRAND FINALE!
♪ ♪ ♪
>> DIONNE AND I, LIKE,
BUMP INTO EACH OTHER.
IT'S A COMPLETE TRAIN WRECK.
THESE GIRLS--THERE'S JUST
SUCH A LACK OF EXPERIENCE.
>> DID YOU HAVE A GOOD TIME?
>> OH, WONDERFUL!
>> YES!
>> OF COURSE IT WAS, IN FACT,
A CHALLENGE,
AND IT--ALTHOUGH SOME OF YOU
DID VERY WELL,
MOST OF THE TIME
THERE WERE SOME CAR WRECKS
ON THAT RUNWAY.
UM, NATASHA, YOU SEEMED
NOT ALWAYS COGNIZANT
OF WHERE THE OTHER GIRLS WERE
ON THE RUNWAY.
SAMANTHA,
IN THE GHETTO FABULOUS OUTFIT,
YOU'RE SUPPOSED TO HAVE
A LITTLE HIP-HOP,
A LITTLE SWAGGER,
AND YOU DIDN'T--
YOU DIDN'T QUITE HOLD THAT.
SARAH, NOW WHEN YOU
SAW YOUR DRESS OPENING,
WHAT WERE YOU THINKING?
>> "OH, NO." (laughs)
>> IT WAS A HIGH SCHOOL.
THERE WERE KIDS.
IT WOULD NOT HAVE
HURT YOU AT ALL
JUST TO KIND OF HOLD IT UP
A LITTLE BIT
AS YOU WALKED A LITTLE SLOWER.
>> OKAY. I DIDN'T KNOW.
>> RENEE--RENEE, YOU WERE
A LITTLE BIT LOST
IN THE SHUFFLE,
AND ALSO, YOU ALSO SEEMED
TO LAG BEHIND THE CHOREOGRAPHY.
>> I REALLY DON'T CARE.
THE CROWD WAS LOVING ME,
SO I FEEL LIKE
I DID REALLY GOOD.
>> MOVING RIGHT ALONG
TO BRITTANY...
I THOUGHT THAT, IN FACT,
YOU HAD THE BEST STAGE PRESENCE.
A COUPLE TIMES, I SAW
YOUR PERIPHERAL VISION SLIP,
AND YOU SORT OF RAN TO CATCH UP
WITH THE OTHER GIRLS.
BUT YOU ALWAYS
MANAGED TO CATCH UP,
AND THAT'S WHAT'S IMPORTANT.
JASLENE, I ACTUALLY THOUGHT
THAT YOU WERE PRETTY LOST
ON THE RUNWAY.
YOU WERE VERY UNSURE
OF YOURSELF.
YOU MADE PROBABLY
THE MOST MISTAKES.
>> WHEN HE TELLS ME
HIS CRITICISM,
I WAS IN SHOCK.
I WAS LIKE, WHOA.
BECAUSE I WAS FEELING SO GOOD
ABOUT MYSELF,
AND I KNOW I DID VERY WELL.
>> IF YOU SEE YOUR FELLOW MODEL
COMING TO YOU
AND YOU'RE SUPPOSED TO CROSS,
YOU TAKE THAT LITTLE PAUSE
TO ALLOW HER TO CROSS,
BUT YOU KEPT ON GOING.
>> JASLENE WAS THE WORST ONE
OUT THERE,
AND SHE'S REALLY UPSET.
>> SO AS MUCH FUN AS THIS WAS,
THIS, IN FACT, WAS A CHALLENGE.
AND THE WINNER
OF THIS CHALLENGE IS...
BRITTANY.
>> YEAH!
>> (laughs)
>> ALL RIGHT!
>> GOOD JOB.
>> CONGRATULATIONS.
CONGRATULATIONS. YOUR TROPHY.
>> THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
IT FEELS REALLY GOOD
TO WIN A CHALLENGE.
IT'S EXCITING.
>> TURN IT AROUND SO YOU CAN SEE
THAT YOUR NAME
IS ON THE FRONT OF IT.
>> (laughs)
BRITTANY WINS
THIS RIDONKULOUSLY BIG TROPHY
WITH, LIKE, A SPRAY-PAINTED SHOE
ON THE TOP OF IT.
♪ ♪ ♪
>> (laughs)
>> THANK YOU.
>> BE PROUD.
>> I AM PROUD!
'CAUSE I DO KNOW
THAT THIS IS A COMPETITION.
>> HOW DID YOU FEEL ABOUT
THAT CRITIQUE HE GAVE YOU?
>> I WAS LIKE, HOLD ON.
LIKE, I KNOW I WASN'T
THE ONLY ONE WHO MADE MISTAKES.
YOU KNOW, HE MADE IT SEEM LIKE
I WAS THE WORST ONE.
LIKE, PLEASE.
I FELT SO CONFIDENT UP THERE.
>> I THINK THAT JASLENE
IS VERY SELF-CENTERED,
VERY, UM, COCKY.
BUT AT THE SAME TIME,
SHE'S VERY INSECURE.
>> AM I THE ONLY PERSON
THAT FEELS THIS TENSION?
>> NO. LORD, IT'S BREWING.
>> JASLENE'S CRITIQUE
WAS THAT SHE DID THE WORST,
SO THERE'S TENSION RISING.
ATTITUDES IS CHANGING REAL QUICK
AND I FEEL IT.
>> OH, YEAH.
>> PEOPLE MAD 'CAUSE
THEY NOT AT THE TOP NO MORE.
PEOPLE MAD BECAUSE THEY--
YOU KNOW, IT'S JUST...
LET'S ALL HANG AROUND, GIRLS.
>> I COULD HEAR FELICIA
IN THE CORNER, TALKING,
AND IMMEDIATELY
I PUT MY GUARDS UP
BECAUSE I KNEW IT WAS
GOING TOWARDS ME.
>> IF SHE IS MAD
ABOUT THAT TROPHY...
BRITTANY DESERVED IT.
>> I RATHER US TO TALK ABOUT IT
LIKE GROWN ADULTS.
SO RIGHT AWAY, I JUST--
I WANTED TO CONFRONT HER
ABOUT IT.
>> Y'ALL WANT A WASHCLOTH?
>> OKAY... AND YOUR POINT?
>> BUT YOU CAUSING DRAMA.
YOU WANT IT. SO, LIKE, IF YOU--
YOU TALKING ABOUT TENSION...
>> OKAY, SO IF EVERYBODY AGREES
ON THE SAME THING...
THIS ARGUING RIGHT HERE,
YOU TALKING TO ME, SO JUST STOP.
>> DUMB-ASS.
WITH THE COMPETITION,
IT'S VERY EASY FOR YOU
TO GET CAUGHT UP INTO THE DRAMA
THAT'S OCCURRING.
>> SOME GIRL
COMES INSIDE THE HOUSE,
AND SHE COMMENTS,
"OH, WELL, NOW THE ONES
WHO THOUGHT THEY WERE ON TOP--
THEY'RE ON THE BOTTOM."
THEY'RE MAD
BECAUSE I'M THE BEST WALKER.
LIKE, YOU COULD TELL, MA.
LIKE, THEY JUST TRYING
TO BRING ME DOWN,
AND, YOU KNOW, LIKE, THAT HURTS.
>> Look at you.
You're not being strong enough.
They--
>> NO, I HAVE BEEN.
BUT, MOM, I'M TALKING TO YOU.
CAN I AT LEAST CRY TO YOU?
I DON'T HAVE NOBODY OUT HERE.
>> I-I SEE THAT JASLENE HAS
SUCH A BIG FRONT ON RIGHT NOW,
AND IT'S STARTING TO BREAK DOWN.
IT'S STARTING TO, YOU KNOW,
CRUMBLE.
I TOLD YOU GUYS.
EVERYBODY'S ALL,
WE'RE ALL BEST FRIENDS,
AND WE'RE NOT GONNA BE FIGHTING
IN THIS HOUSE...
>> OH, HECK NO.
>> BUT I SAID, PFFT.
WAIT TILL THE FIRST ELIMINATION
IS OVER.
>> (crying) I SWEAR,
I'M LIKE A TIME BOMB, MOM.
BUT THESE GIRLS,
THE WAY THEY ARE, MOM,
LIKE, I'M GONNA BLOW UP.
>> TYRA MAIL!
>> TYRA MAIL.
"I'M SO GLAD WE'RE B.F.F.s.
GOOD LUCK IN ALL YOU DO,
AND DON'T FORGET TO K.I.T.
LOVE, TYRA."
(crickets chirping)
>> AND NATASHA--
IT'S SOMETIMES HARD
TO GET HER POINT ACROSS
BECAUSE OF THE LANGUAGE BARRIER.
>> "DON'T FORGET TO K.I.T."
>> OH, "DON'T FORGET
TO KEEP IN TOUCH."
>> ARE WE GOING SOMEWHERE?
>> WE'RE DRIVING IN THE LIMO
AND ARRIVE AT THE HIGH SCHOOL,
AND WE'RE LIKE,
WE'RE BACK AT HIGH SCHOOL AGAIN.
>> GOOD MORNING!
YOU GUYS HAVE BEEN LEARNING
ABOUT RUNWAY THIS WEEK,
AND YOU WERE AT SCHOOL ALL WEEK,
SO I THOUGHT
IT ONLY MADE SENSE
THAT WE WOULD GO BACK TO SCHOOL
FOR YOUR PHOTO SHOOT TODAY.
WE'RE ACTUALLY GOING TO DO
SCENES THAT ACT OUT
THOSE AWARDS THAT THEY GIVE OUT
AT THE END OF THE YEAR.
YOU KNOW WHAT I'M TALKING ABOUT?
THOSE ARE CALLED
HIGH SCHOOL CLICHéS.
OKAY, RENEE,
YOU'RE GONNA BE THE CLASS CLOWN.
WHITNEY--MEAN GIRL.
>> (laughs)
>> JAEL--THE BOOKWORM.
(laughs)
FELICIA--THE JOCK.
CASSANDRA,
YOU'RE GONNA BE THE CHEERLEADER.
ALL RIGHT?
JASLENE--THE WEIRDO GIRL.
DIANA--THE STUDENT BODY
PRESIDENT.
BRITTANY--THE VALEDICTORIAN.
OKAY, DIONNE--THE BAD GIRL.
NATASHA, YOU ARE GOING TO BE
THE TEACHER'S PET TODAY.
LOOK AT HER!
SHE'S LIKE, WHAT'S THAT?
OKAY, SARAH--THE CLASS FLIRT.
SAMANTHA, YOU'RE GONNA BE
THE GIRL WITH
THE BAD REPUTATION.
OKAY?
>> OH!
>> WE HAD TO BRING IN SOMEONE
WHO COULD REALLY
MAKE THOSE HIGH SCHOOL HAIRDOS
AN ABSOLUTE AMAZING SUCCESS.
HER NAME IS HALLIE BOWMAN.
>> YEAH!
>> (cheering)
>> I'M HERBAL ESSENCES'
PROFESSIONAL STYLIST,
AND I'M HERE TODAY
WITH THEIR ENTIRE NEW LINE
OF SHAMPOOS AND CONDITIONERS
AND STYLERS
THAT WILL TAKE YOUR HAIR
ALL THE WAY TO LUSCIOUS.
>> SO YOU GUYS, UH,
READY TO GO GET STARTED?
>> YEAH!
♪ ♪ ♪
>> THE DANGEROUSLY STRAIGHT LINE
IS MEANT FOR YOU
TO BE ABLE TO CRAFT, LIKE,
THE PERFECT,
PERILOUSLY STRAIGHT LOOK.
>> AND IT SMELLS GOOD!
>> I AM CHOSEN TO PLAY THE NERD.
I'M SO HAPPY ABOUT MY LOOK.
IT'S DEFINITELY
SOMETHING I WOULD WEAR
ON A NORMAL OCCASION.
>> THAT'S A CUTE POSE
RIGHT THERE.
>> I TOTALLY WISH I COULD
TAKE THOSE GLASSES HOME WITH ME,
BRING OUT THE NERD
INSIDE OF MY SOUL.
>> LIKE, REALLY LAUGH.
>> YEAH. THERE WE GO.
>> A FLIRTY GIRL'S
NOT AFRAID OF FLIRTING.
LOOKING OVER, I MEAN, LIKE, HEY.
(camera shutter snapping)
>> I LIKE THE LITTLE GIGGLE.
LET HIM CAPTURE IT.
>> RIGHT THERE.
>> GO WITH YOUR FIRST INSTINCT.
>> YEAH.
>> I'M TELLING YOU, SARAH,
YOU KNOW WHAT YOU'RE DOING.
>> I THINK THAT
BECAUSE I DO THE PHOTOGRAPHY
AND I HAVE DONE THE MODELING,
I THINK ABOUT IT TOO MUCH,
SO I HAVE THE TENDENCY
TO OVERANALYZE MYSELF.
>> THAT'S YOUR MARKER...
>> OKAY.
>> SO TRY AND STAY CLOSE
TO THAT.
>> LET'S GO.
I'M NOT A BAD GIRL.
>> ARE YOU JUST THINKING
OF POSING
AND TRYING TO LOOK HARD?
>> I COULD'VE DID
THE--THE SLUTTY THING.
YOU KNOW, I'M GOOD
WITH SEDUCING PEOPLE.
>> THERE WE GO.
THAT'S THE GIRL
WE'RE LOOKING FOR.
>> THIS IS THE TOTALLY TWISTED
FROM HERBAL ESSENCES--
RADIANTLY SHINY
AND DEFINITELY DEFINED CURLS.
>> MY THEME IS UNIQUE
BECAUSE I GOT TO BE RELUCTANT
AND HAVE MY FACE
BE MORE LIKE, WHATEVER,
WHICH IS MORE HIGH FASHION
TO ME.
>> I JUST FEEL LIKE
THE--THE SHOT'S A LITTLE DULL.
>> OKAY.
>> AND YOU'RE NOT DULL.
>> LAST FRAME.
>> MAKE IT STRONG. OKAY.
>> OKAY.
>> JAY ASSIGNED ME CLASS CLOWN,
SO I'M--
I'M A LITTLE BIT PIFFED.
I'M A LITTLE BIT LIKE,
WHY CAN'T I GET SOMETHING
THAT I'M GOOD AT?
BECAUSE SOME OF THE OTHER GIRLS
ARE GETTING THINGS
THAT THEY'RE GOOD AT.
>> YOU READY? SHOWTIME.
>> YOU CAN ASK JAEL.
MAYBE SHE'LL HELP YOU.
>> WELL, I THINK YOU SHOULD
BE BIGGER WITH YOUR ARMS.
>> I'M NOT VERY HAPPY
THAT JAEL AND SARAH ARE SITTING
IN THE PHOTO SHOOT WITH ME.
I WISH THAT THEY WOULD'VE
ASKED ME FIRST.
>> PINUP.
>> OKAY, NOW THAT'S PINUP GIRL
GOING, "OOH." >> YEAH.
>> OKAY.
>> THE CLASS CLOWN'S
KIND OF LIKE,
LOOK, I'M FLASHING IT.
RENEE WAS A LITTLE PAINFUL
TO WATCH, BECAUSE RENEE DID NOT
KIND OF COME OUT OF HER SHELL.
UNFORTUNATELY, SHE DIDN'T HAVE
THE BEST RANGE OF EXPRESSIONS.
>> THAT'S NOT ME AT ALL,
SO HOPEFULLY I CAN DO IT.
>> IT'S NOT?
>> NO.
YEAH, WELL, LAST WEEK
PROBABLY WASN'T YOU EITHER.
>> NO.
LAST WEEK, I WAS A LESBIAN,
AND NOW I'M A HO.
(laughs) SO MUCH FUN.
>> SELL IT.
GIVE ME A LITTLE MORE HIP.
THINKING OF YOUR BOYFRIEND?
>> YEAH.
>> DON'T THINK ABOUT
YOUR BOYFRIEND.
THINK ABOUT THE OTHER ONE.
IT'LL WORK.
>> I DON'T HAVE ANOTHER ONE.
>> OH! OH!
>> AT FIRST,
I WASN'T VERY EXCITED,
MAINLY BECAUSE THAT WASN'T ME
IN HIGH SCHOOL
AND STILL NOT ME.
>> GO AHEAD.
PUT YOUR HANDS
ON YOUR INNER THIGH A LITTLE.
>> YEAH.
>> PRETEND YOU'RE TOTALLY ALONE
AND YOU'RE... (boing)
>> OH, MY GOSH,
HE JUST SAID... (boing)
>> EVERYBODY DOES IT!
>> YEAH.
>> I DON'T EVEN TALK LIKE THAT
AROUND, LIKE, MY REALLY CLOSE,
LIKE, GIRLFRIENDS.
I DON'T KNOW. IT NEVER COMES UP.
>> WHAT ARE YOU THINKING
RIGHT NOW, SAMANTHA?
>> I DON'T KNOW.
>> AND IT READS
ALL OVER THE FRAME.
>> I HONESTLY FEEL LIKE
I COULD'VE ROCKED IT, LIKE,
TEN TIMES BETTER THAN SAMANTHA.
SHE'S NOT COMFORTABLE
BEING SEXY,
BUT IT'S VERY EASY TO BE SEXY.
>> YOU READY TO DO THIS?
>> I THINK SO.
>> OKAY, WHAT ARE YOU DOING?
TIP YOUR HEAD BACK.
THERE YOU GO. MUCH BETTER.
BRITT LOOKS LIKE A MODEL.
SHE KNOWS HOW TO CARRY OFF
THE CLOTHING.
GOOD JOB, BRITT.
>> GOOD JOB.
>> YEAH!
>> OOH, THE MEAN GIRL.
SHE GOT THE BAG, THE GLASSES.
YOU HATIN'?
>> PERFECT.
>> IN HIGH SCHOOL,
I WASN'T THE MEAN GIRL,
BUT I KNOW WHAT IT'S LIKE
TO, YOU KNOW,
WHISPER ABOUT OTHERS
AND NOT BE SO NICE ALL THE TIME.
(laughs)
>> YEAH, REMEMBER,
THE MEAN GIRLS
ARE NOT ALWAYS SCOWLY.
THE MEAN GIRLS ARE VERY FAKE.
"OH, I LOVE YOU... BITCH."
(laughs)
>> I FELT LIKE WHITNEY COULD'VE
GONE A LITTLE FURTHER
AND KIND OF CREATED
A DEEPER CHARACTER THERE.
REALLY STRONG.
POP THAT BOOTY OUT.
THERE YOU GO.
>> I FIGURED
I'D BE KIND OF SEXY,
CONFIDENT, YOU KNOW.
THE WHOLE TIME, I WAS THINKING,
VOTE FOR ME. VOTE FOR ME.
>> EVER SEE THOSE NIKE ADS
WHERE THERE'S, LIKE,
REALLY COOL JUMPING IN THE AIR,
LIKE... WAH!
FELICIA IS VERY GRACEFUL.
SHE KNOWS HOW TO CREATE
DYNAMIC BODY SHAPES.
THERE YOU GO.
>> I'M GONNA SPRAY THIS,
THE SHIMMERY NIGHTS.
WE WANT THIS TO LOOK, LIKE,
VERY GOTHY.
>> THAT WAS THE LOOK.
YEP, THAT WAS ME.
>> I WASN'T WATCHING
NONE OF THEIR PHOTO SHOOTS.
I'M NOT GONNA LEARN ANYTHING
FROM THEM.
IF ANYTHING,
THEY'RE GONNA LEARN FROM ME.
>> USE YOUR HAND.
YOU CAN REACH UP ON THAT POLE
AND KIND OF--YEAH, THERE WE GO.
BEAUTIFUL. THAT'S IT.
>> I LOVE IT.
WE'RE NOT EVEN AT FRAME 20,
AND I'M DONE WITH YOU ALREADY.
>> AS UGLY AS I LOOKED,
I STILL MANAGED TO SOCK IT.
YOU KNOW, LIKE,
I JUST GAVE IT TO THEM.
>> OH, MY GOD!
CAN YOU GIVE ME
ONE BAD SHOT FOR THE DAY?
THEY'RE GORGEOUS!
>> I WISH THAT I WAS GIVEN
SOMETHING THAT I WAS GOOD AT.
JASLENE--I FEEL LIKE...
I DON'T KNOW.
SHE ALWAYS GET THE FIERCE THING.
YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN?
IF I HAD THOSE LOOKS,
THEN I--THEN I WOULD'VE,
YOU KNOW, DONE REALLY GOOD
AND I WOULD'VE GOT
REALLY GOOD FEEDBACK,
AND I'D BE MORE CONFIDENT.
>> HAVE YOU EVER BEEN
THE TEACHER'S PET BEFORE?
>> NO.
>> NEVER?
>> UNH-UNH.
BY THE EXPRESSION ON MY FACE,
MR. JAY JUST KNOW THAT
I DON'T UNDERSTAND THE CONCEPT
OF THE TEACHER'S PET.
LIKE, SHOULD I BE INNOCENT
OR MORE SEXY?
LIKE...
>> NOT SEXY, FOR SURE.
>> OKAY.
>> NATASHA, I DON'T THINK
THE SITTING IS WORKING AT ALL.
WHY DON'T YOU JUST IMITATE
WHAT YOU SEE IN A MAGAZINE?
A LITTLE MORE GRACEFUL
WITH THAT LEG,
SO IT DOESN'T LOOK LIKE
YOU'RE SITTING ON THE TOILET.
WITHIN THIS WIDE STANCE,
MAKE IT WORK.
I WAS TRYING TO SHOW NATASHA
HOW TO POSE.
THE PROBLEM IS,
SHE REALLY DOESN'T
UNDERSTAND MODELING.
I AM SEEING YOUR THOUGHT PROCESS
ALL OVER YOUR FACE.
IT'S... NOT GENUINE AT ALL.
>> IT'S HARD FOR ME TO GET
'CAUSE I DON'T TALK
A LOT OF ENGLISH.
I DON'T SPEAK BASIC WORDS.
I-I TALK LIKE A FOREIGNER.
I FEEL LIKE I'M FAILING.
(crying)
♪ ♪ ♪
>> I WAS JUST UP--UPSET
WITH THE LOOK THAT I WAS GIVEN.
I FEEL LIKE THEY'RE--
THEY'RE GIVING ME
A MUCH HARDER TIME.
THEY WANT YOU
TO SHOW PERSONALITY.
THEY WANT YOU TO SHOW, LIKE,
WHAT YOU'VE GOT,
BUT THEY KEEP GIVING ME STUFF
THAT THEY KNOW I'M GONNA--
NOT GONNA BE GOOD AT.
YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN?
>> ME, TOO. LIKE, I SPEAK A LOT
WITH MY EYES.
>> NO, I DO, TOO.
>> AH, WHATEVER.
I FEEL LIKE
JASLENE'S GETTING, YOU KNOW,
ALL THE COOL PHOTO SHOOTS.
AND YOU KNOW WHAT? I GOT IT.
I CAN SHOW YOU FIERCE.
I CAN SHOW YOU ANGRY.
I CAN SHOW YOU SEXY.
IF YOU'RE GONNA TAKE ONE GIRL
OUT OF HER ELEMENT,
YOU NEED TO TAKE ALL OF THEM
OUT OF THEIR ELEMENT.
>> IT DOES NOT MATTER.
I JUST FEEL LIKE
SHE'S PLAYING EXCUSES.
♪ ♪ ♪
>> TYRA MAIL!
>> NEW TYRA MAIL!
>> AAH! AAH!
>> JAEL WAS
PRANCING AROUND THE HOUSE
HALF-NAKED.
SOME PEOPLE ARE NOT COMFORTABLE
WITH THAT.
>> "TOMORROW
YOU WILL MEET WITH THE JUDGES.
ONLY 11 WILL CONTINUE ON
IN THE HOPES OF BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL."
>> OOH!
>> WHOO!
>> I THINK THERE'S ALWAYS
A TIME AND A PLACE TO HAVE FUN
AND TO BE REALLY LOUD
AND, YOU KNOW...
AND YOU DON'T HAVE TO
BE LIKE THAT ALL THE TIME.
>> CAN I GET A, UH, CLAP-CLAP?
>> WHOO!
>> IT'S REALLY HARD TO EXPLAIN
HOW YOU COULD FEEL SO ALONE
IN A HOUSE WITH SO MANY PEOPLE.
♪ ♪ ♪
>> I COULD NOT RECOLLECT, UH,
TEACHER'S PET IN MY MIND
BECAUSE I'VE NEVER HAD EXAMPLE.
I'M ALWAYS NERVOUS
BEFORE ELIMINATION.
MY PHOTO SHOOT DIDN'T GO WELL.
>> NOBODY'S SENDING YOU HOME.
>> (laughs) REALLY?
>> LOOK AT YOU.
>> IT WAS VERY STRESSFUL DAY
FOR ME.
I THINK IT WAS
THE MOST STRESSFUL DAY
I EVER HAD IN HERE.
I'M VERY NERVOUS
'CAUSE I DON'T WANT TO GO HOME.
♪ ♪ ♪
>> HELLO, LADIES.
>> HELLO!
>> I HAVE TO SAY,
YOU ALL LOOK QUITE SMASHING.
ESPECIALLY THIS EARLY
IN THE COMPETITION.
USUALLY,
THE GIRLS ARE STILL LOOKING
A LITTLE BROKE DOWN.
SO BRAVO.
THE FABULOUS PRIZES--
A CONTRACT
WITH THE MODELING AGENCY,
ELITE MODEL MANAGEMENT,
WHICH IS ONE OF
THE TOP MODELING AGENCIES
IN THE ENTIRE WORLD...
A COVER AND A 6-PAGE SPREAD
OF "SEVENTEEN" MAGAZINE...
AND A $100,000 CONTRACT
WITH COVERGIRL COSMETICS.
AND YOU KNOW ABOUT THE JUDGES--
NOTED FASHION PHOTOGRAPHER
NIGEL BARKER...
AND WE HAVE MISS J. ALEXANDER--
LAST WEEK, HAD ON ONE RUFFLE,
THIS WEEK, SPORTING TWO.
AT THE END OF THIS CYCLE,
HE WILL HAVE 12,
REPRESENTING THE GIRLS
THAT WANTED TO BE
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL
BUT DIDN'T ACTUALLY GET THERE.
>> (laughs)
>> AND OF COURSE,
WE HAVE TWIGGY,
OUR FASHION ICON...
AND YOU SEE
THIS LOVELY GENTLEMAN HERE,
MR. ROY CAMPBELL,
WHO I HAVE KNOWN
SINCE I WAS 17 YEARS OLD.
HE WROTE THE VERY FIRST ARTICLE
ABOUT ME IN A FASHION MAGAZINE.
SO NOW IT'S TIME
FOR YOUR INDIVIDUAL EVALUATIONS.
FIRST UP IS SARAH.
ALL RIGHT, SARAH,
SO YOU HAD A PHOTO SHOOT
WHERE YOU HAD TO BE
A HIGH SCHOOL CLICHé,
AND WHAT WAS THAT?
>> I WAS THE CLASS FLIRT.
>> LET'S SEE YOUR BEST SHOT.
>> SARAH,
THIS IS A GREAT ROLE FOR YOU.
YOU'VE GOT THAT NATURAL
FLIRTATIOUS TENDENCIES.
>> IT'S A LITTLE BIT TOO SEXY,
I-I WOULD THINK.
BECAUSE THERE'S THAT FINE LINE
BETWEEN FASHION
AND MEN'S MAGAZINES.
>> MR. JAY SAID THAT YOU NEED
TO TRUST YOUR INSTINCTS,
BECAUSE YOU OVERTHINK
WHAT YOU'RE DOING,
YOU LOOK TOO STUDIED
AND YOU DON'T
HOLD YOUR POSES LONG ENOUGH.
>> MM-HMM.
>> UP NEXT IS CASSANDRA.
YOU HAD A PHOTO SHOOT
WHERE YOU HAD TO BE
A HIGH SCHOOL CLICHé,
AND WHAT WAS THAT?
>> I WAS THE CHEERLEADER.
I WAS TRYING TO THINK
OF BEING MORE LIKE,
OH, I DON'T WANT TO BE HERE.
>> IN YOUR LONG SHOT,
I THINK YOU MAKE
ONE HELL OF A CHEERLEADER.
>> THERE'S NO FIRE IN YOUR EYES.
>> SHE'S A LITTLE MORE LIKE...
>> MM-HMM.
>> BORED IS...
(sighs)
A PICTURE'S ALWAYS ABOUT
AN EXAGGERATION.
>> OKAY.
>> THANK YOU.
UP NEXT WE HAVE DIANA.
WHICH A HIGH SCHOOL CLICHé
WERE YOU?
>> I WAS THE CLASS PRESIDENT.
>> YOU'VE GOT
GOOD BODY LANGUAGE.
YOU KNOW WHAT I LIKE ABOUT IT,
IS THE SNOOTY FACTOR.
"HEY, LOOK AT ME.
I'M KIND OF TOO IMPORTANT
FOR YOU."
I THINK YOU'RE IN CONTROL
OF THE PICTURE.
>> I AGREE.
THERE'S A LOT GOING ON.
THERE'S A CAMERA THERE
CAPTURING YOU
WITH YOUR CLASS SPEECH,
THERE'S A POSTER THERE,
BUT I'M LOOKING AT YOU.
>> THANK YOU.
>> ALL RIGHT, UP NEXT IS DIONNE.
ALL RIGHT, DIONNE,
WHICH ONE WERE YOU?
>> I WAS THE BAD GIRL.
>> I LIKE THAT SHE'S ON
THE TEACHER'S DESK.
SHE'S JUST A REBEL.
>> BEAUTIFUL.
>> AND THE EYES
LOOK A LITTLE NAUGHTY, TOO,
WHICH IS GOOD.
>> MM-HMM.
>> YOU'VE GOT
THAT BAD GIRL INSTINCT IN YOU.
THE BODY LANGUAGE WAS GOOD HERE.
>> JUST ENOUGH MOVEMENT
IN THE FACE TO GIVE THAT
"MM-HMM, YEAH."
>> MM-HMM, THE LITTLE POUT.
>> IT'S JUST A LITTLE "MMM."
>> (whispers) THANK YOU.
>> ALL RIGHT,
UP NEXT IS BRITTANY.
BRITTANY,
YOU WERE THE CHALLENGE WINNER.
CONGRATULATIONS.
(applause)
>> YOU HAD A PHOTO SHOOT
WHERE YOU HAD TO BE WHAT?
>> I WAS THE VALEDICTORIAN.
>> I THINK YOU'VE GOT
A-A TIMELESS FACE,
WHICH IS WHAT
I LIKE TO LOOK FOR.
>> I THINK THIS IS
A SUPERB PICTURE.
YOU'RE VALEDICTORIAN.
IT LOOKS LIKE IT.
>> YES.
>> YOU LOOK CLEVER
AND YOU LOOK LIKE A MODEL.
YOU NAILED IT.
>> THANK YOU.
>> NEXT UP IS SAMANTHA.
YOU WERE...
>> I WAS THE GIRL WITH
THE BAD REPUTATION,
LIKE, THE--THE CLASS TRAMP.
>> SHE DON'T LOOK TRAMPY ENOUGH
FOR ME.
>> NO.
>> I DON'T GET THAT SENSE
OF NAUGHTINESS, OF...
YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN?
"I'M GOING UNDER THE BLEACHERS
WITH YOU."
THAT'S NOT THERE.
>> THAT'S WHY
SHE'S BY THE BLEACHERS!
>> EXACTLY.
>> I SAW YOUR FILM,
AND YOU DID DO
SOME MORE SEXY STUFF.
YOU JUST SEEMED SO UNSURE.
"I THINK I'M A HO?"
(laughter)
>> MOST MODELING
IS KIND OF ACTING LIKE A HO
BUT MAKING IT FASHION.
HO... BUT THEN MAKE IT FASHION.
HO... MAKE IT FASHION.
UP NEXT IS FELICIA.
YOU HAD TO BE
A HIGH SCHOOL CLICHé,
WHICH WAS WHAT?
>> THE JOCK.
>> WOW.
>> MMM!
>> YEAH. OUTSTANDING.
YOU ACTUALLY DID NAIL THIS SHOT.
YOU HAVE A CLASSIC FACE,
AND YOU SHOULD BE
PROUD OF YOURSELF.
>> WHY DID Y'ALL
PUT THAT PICTURE
OF TYRA BANKS UP THERE?
WHY ARE Y'ALL FRONTIN'?
>> REALLY?
YOU HAD SO MANY GOOD SHOTS.
>> THANK YOU.
>> YOU KNOW HOW TO JUMP.
I THINK IT'S FROM YOUR DANCING.
AND YOU KEEP YOUR FACE GOOD.
OKAY, THANKS, FELICIA.
UP NEXT IS JAEL.
WHICH HIGH SCHOOL CLICHé
WERE YOU?
>> HIGH SCHOOL NERD.
(laughter)
>> I LIKE IT BECAUSE
IT IS NERDY BUT FASHION.
>> YOU LIKE MY PHOTO
A LITTLE BIT?
>> I LIKE YOUR PHOTO, JAEL!
>> OKAY! ALL RIGHT.
>> LOOK AT HER EYES.
>> MM-HMM.
>> THE WAY YOU'VE DELIVERED
IN THIS PICTURE...
THE BODY LANGUAGE IS GOOD.
YOU GOT IT.
>> ALL RIGHT.
NEXT UP IS JASLENE.
ALL RIGHT,
SO YOU HAD A PHOTO SHOOT
WHERE YOU HAD TO BE
THE HIGH SCHOOL WHAT?
>> THE WEIRDO.
>> I THINK IT'S FABULOUS.
>> YEAH, IT'S A GREAT SHOT.
>> I LOVE IT.
>> I CAN SEE THAT IN A MAGAZINE
RIGHT NOW.
>> OKAY, GIRLS IN THE HOUSE,
LOOK OUT.
Y'ALL BETTER GET IT TOGETHER,
COME TOGETHER, GET IT TOGETHER.
>> THEY'RE ON ME ALREADY.
>> THEY'RE ON YOU HOW?
>> THEY'RE SCATTERED AROUND
THE HOUSE JUST TALKING ABOUT ME.
I FEEL LIKE MOST OF 'EM
ARE BEING PHONY.
THIS IS THE HAPPIEST I'VE BEEN,
YOU KNOW, BEING HERE,
'CAUSE NOT ONLY DO IT WANT THIS
BUT I DESIRE THIS...
(voice breaking) AND I DON'T
LIKE TO FEEL UNCOMFORTABLE.
>> BEING PHONY
IS PART OF FASHION.
PEOPLE KISS YOU ON YOUR CHECK
AND STAB YOU IN THE BACK.
THAT'S THE REALITY.
IT DON'T HAVE TO BE REAL.
YOU JUST HAVE TO GET ALONG
WITH PEOPLE.
>> JASLENE, YOU KNOW,
YOU'VE GOTTA HAVE
A BIT THICKER SKIN THAN THAT.
>> LET THEM HATE YOU.
JUST DO YOUR THING.
>> YEAH.
>> AND YOU DID YOUR THING
WITH THIS PHOTO, MAMA.
>> THANK YOU.
>> UP NEXT IS WHITNEY.
AND YOU WERE THE...
>> I WAS THE MEAN GIRL.
>> WHAT YOU HAVE TO WORK ON
IS THE BODY LANGUAGE TO MAKE IT
A LITTLE BIT MORE EXTREME.
>> YEAH.
>> IT READS IN THE CLOSE-UP
BUT NOT IN THE LONG SHOT.
>> GOING THROUGH YOUR FILM,
IT WAS--IT WAS HARD FOR ME
TO CHOOSE A SHOT FOR YOU.
I DIDN'T SEE
A LOT OF DIFFERENT RANGE.
IT JUST FEELS LIKE
YOU WERE THINKING
ONE-DIMENSIONALLY,
AND YOU COULD'VE GONE FURTHER.
>> IT WAS LITTLE DIFFICULT, TOO,
'CAUSE I HAD MARKS
THAT I HAD TO HIT.
>> I JUST DID A SHOOT
FOR "VANITY FAIR,"
AND THE PHOTOGRAPHER
WAS MICHAEL ROBERTS,
AND HE PLACED AND HE SAID,
"DON'T MOVE."
>> MMM.
>> (laughs)
>> BUT I STILL WAS LIKE...
SO YOU CAN'T USE THE MARK
AS AN EXCUSE.
UP NEXT IS RENEE.
YOU WERE A HIGH SCHOOL WHAT?
>> I WAS THE CLASS CLOWN.
>> YOU LOOK LIKE
YOU'RE HAVING FUN.
YOU LOOK LIKE YOU ARE CLOWNIN'.
>> IT'S JUST
A REALLY PRETTY PICTURE, TOO.
>> MM-HMM.
>> YOU KNOW WHAT?
THE FIRST FEW SHOTS,
IT TOOK ME A LITTLE BIT
TO, LIKE, BREAK THROUGH THAT.
>> I STILL SAY WATCH THE FACE,
'CAUSE YOU'RE GONNA MESS UP
A LOT OF GREAT, AMAZING SHOTS
BY NOT BEING CONSCIOUS ENOUGH
WITH THE FACE WHILE DOING
CRAZY THINGS WITH YOUR BODY.
>> I LIKE--LOVE THE FACT
THAT YOU'RE REALLY COMMITTED
TO THIS PICTURE.
THERE'S A LOT OF ENERGY
IN THAT SHOT, BUT I THINK
YOU'VE GOT A LOT MORE
THAT YOU COULD GIVE US.
>> IT WAS GOOD, NOT GREAT.
>> YEAH, EXACTLY.
>> YES.
>> OKAY.
>> AND LAST BUT NOT LEAST
IS NATASHA.
SO, NATASHA,
YOU HAD TO BE A WHAT?
>> TEACHER'S PET.
>> I DON'T GET "TEACHER'S PET"
FROM THAT.
>> NO.
>> YOU HAVE SUCH
AN EXTRAORDINARY FACE, I THINK.
>> I DON'T THINK YOU QUITE
FIGURED OUT "TEACHER'S PET."
MAYBE IT'S A LANGUAGE BARRIER
FOR YOU?
>> I GET THE WICKED WITCH OF...
WHAT, SNOW WHITE?
WHAT WAS HER NAME?
>> THAT'S 'CAUSE OF THE APPLE.
>> MMM.
>> RELAX YOUR MOUTH.
>> YEAH.
>> WHEN I FIRST
STARTED MODELING,
I USED TO THINK THAT BEING SEXY
WAS PUSHING MY LIPS OUT.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO DO THAT.
YOU NEED TO BRING YOUR INTENSITY
INTO YOUR EYES
AND JUST RELAX THIS.
I CALL IT THE NOVOCAIN MOUTH.
JUST... UH. JAY SAID
THAT YOUR SHOOT WAS THE HARDEST
IN "TOP MODEL" HISTORY
TO DIRECT,
AND THAT YOU'RE WORSE THAN ANN
FROM CYCLE 3 OF "TOP MODEL."
>> I REMEMBER ANN.
SHE WAS ONE OF
THE MOST BEAUTIFUL GIRLS.
(laughter)
>> I LOVE IT.
>> THANK YOU.
>> OH, DON'T YOU LOVE IT?
I LOVE IT!
>> YOU TOOK IT AS A POSITIVE.
FABULOUS.
>> THANK YOU SO MUCH.
>> ALL RIGHT, SO NOW IT'S TIME
FOR THE JUDGES TO DELIBERATE.
WHEN WE CALL YOU BACK,
I WILL ANNOUNCE WHICH ONE OF YOU
WILL BE ELIMINATED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
CLASS DISMISSED.
>> ALL RIGHT, SO NOW IT IS TIME
TO DECIDE WHO IS GOING HOME.
BRITTANY.
>> BRITTANY'S TAKEN
TWO GREAT SHOTS.
THIS IS HER SECOND WEEK
IN A ROW.
FANTASTIC PICTURE OF BRITTANY.
>> BRITTANY WAS PHENOMENAL
ON THE RUNWAY.
>> RENEE.
>> SHE'S GOT A GREAT LOOK
IN PERSON,
BUT IT HASN'T TRANSFORMED
TO A PHOTOGRAPH YET.
>> THERE'S SOMETHING ABOUT RENEE
THAT TOUCHES ME.
I FEEL THAT THIS COMPETITION
IS HELPING HER.
WHITNEY.
>> SHE'S A BIT HOUSEWIFEY
FOR ME.
>> WHITNEY IS
A GREAT PERSONALITY.
>> I THINK WHITNEY IS THAT GIRL
THAT IS IN A DESPERATE NEED
OF A MAKEOVER.
CASSANDRA.
>> I LOVED HER WALK.
I LOVE HER BODY.
>> SHE NEEDS TO MODEL STRONGLY
WITH HER FACE.
SHE NEEDS TO BE VERY PRESENT.
NATASHA.
>> I WANT TO SLAP HER, REALLY,
'CAUSE SHE'S GOT IT ALL, BUT SHE
DOESN'T KNOW HOW TO USE IT.
>> BUT NATASHA'S JUST NOT
REALLY ALL THERE.
LIKE, THE DOTS
AREN'T CONNECTING.
>> (Russian accent)
THANK YOU, I AM CONNECTING.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
YOU SAY I'M BEAUTIFUL.
I LOVE IT.
>> I KNOW.
THAT'S A GOOD THING, RIGHT?
EVERY NEGATIVE
BECOMES A POSITIVE.
>> (normal voice) DIANA.
>> I JUST WOULD LIKE TO SEE
A LITTLE MORE ENERGY
AND LESS CONTROL.
>> DIANA'S FACE
LOOKS LIKE A MODEL TO ME.
I LOVE HER PROUDNESS.
>> JASLENE.
>> NO DOUBT, HANDS DOWN,
THIS IS THE BEST SHOT
OF THE BUNCH.
>> SHE NEEDS TO NOT WORRY ABOUT
WHO'S HATING
AND GET HER OWN GAME ON.
>> FASHION IS... FAKE.
"DARLING, YOU LOOK FABULOUS."
>> OKAY.
>> NOW STAB HIM IN THE BACK.
>> (grunting)
>> IF SHE WENT INTO CASTINGS
WITHOUT THE PHOTOGRAPHS,
I DON'T THINK SHE'D GET THE JOB.
>> THE AGENT WOULD ACTUALLY
SEND THE BOOK HOME WITH HER.
(laughter)
>> SARAH.
>> SARAH, I HAVE TO SAY,
DOESN'T PARTICULARLY
DO IT FOR ME.
SHE'S A BIT BIRDLIKE.
>> I ACTUALLY LIKE SARAH.
I THINK SHE NAILED THIS PICTURE.
SARAH'S SOMEBODY
THAT I WOULD DEFINITELY
WANT TO SEE HER DEVELOP
AND GET MORE OPPORTUNITIES.
>> SAMANTHA.
>> SAMANTHA IS ONE OF
THE BEST-LOOKING GIRLS HERE.
BUT I DON'T SEE SAMANTHA
AS HAVING ANY PERSONALITY.
>> I ACTUALLY LOVE
THE WAY SHE PHOTOGRAPHS.
BUT I DO AGREE, THE PERSONALITY
IS A MAJOR, MAJOR PROBLEM.
>> SO MUCH POTENTIAL
BUT SO BOTTLED UP.
IT'S ALMOST LIKE SHE NEEDS
"PRE-AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL"
SCHOOL.
>> YEAH.
>> JAEL.
>> I WOULD PUT A FORK IN HER.
I THINK SHE'S DONE.
>> BABY, LET IT GO.
>> JAEL--WELL, I DIDN'T
UNDERSTAND HER LAST WEEK...
>> I WAS, LIKE, KIND OF NERVOUS
THAT IT WOULD CHANGE THINGS
BETWEEN HOW THE OTHER GIRLS
TREATED ME.
>> AND I DIDN'T UNDERSTAND HER
THIS WEEK.
>> YOU LIKE MY PHOTO, TYRA?
>> YOU GUYS
NEED TO LAY OFF JAEL.
SHE'S TRYING TO FIND HERSELF
AND FIGURE IT OUT.
>> (laughs)
>> DIONNE.
>> IT'S A VERY SAUCY PHOTOGRAPH.
>> YEAH!
>> SHE WENT FOR IT.
>> YOU KNOW,
IF I HAD TO GIVE HER A GRADE,
IT'D DEFINITELY BE A "C."
>> WHY?
>> SHE'S AVERAGE.
>> FELICIA.
>> I THINK THIS IS
A BEAUTIFUL PICTURE OF FELICIA.
I THINK FELICIA'S TAKEN
LOTS OF GREAT SHOTS
AND HAS A LOT TO OFFER.
>> SHE HAS GOT A GREAT BODY.
BUT I'D NEED TO KIND OF
KEEP AN EYE ON HER.
>> I DON'T REALLY SEE ME
IN THIS PICTURE.
KESSE FROM CYCLE 1...
>> I DIDN'T SEE THAT.
NO, I DIDN'T SEE THAT.
>> I THOUGHT
SHE LOOKED LIKE ME A LOT.
BUT FELICIA--I DON'T THINK
I SEE ME IN THIS SHOT.
I'M SORRY. I DON'T.
BUT SHE'S FIERCE.
>> SHE'S SO FIERCE.
(laughter)
>> SHE'S SO FIERCE!
I MEAN, THIS PICTURE
IS SO GORGEOUS!
BUT I DON'T SEE MYSELF.
THIS IS THE BEST PICTURE
IN THE WHOLE BUNCH,
SO WE JUST MIGHT AS WELL
END THE COMPETITION RIGHT NOW!
FELICIA, YOU WON, GIRL!
BUT SHE DON'T LOOK LIKE ME.
(laughter)
>> 12 OF YOU STAND BEFORE ME,
BUT I ONLY HAVE 11 PHOTOS
IN MY HANDS,
AND THESE 11 PHOTOS REPRESENT
THE GIRLS THAT WILL
STILL BE IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
THE FIRST NAME
THAT I'M GOING TO CALL IS...
FOR THE SECOND WEEK IN A ROW,
JASLENE.
>> (exhales deeply)
>> STUNNING, AMAZING,
STRONGEST SHOT OF THE BUNCH...
AGAIN.
>> THANK YOU.
CONGRATULATIONS.
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
>> THANKS.
>> FELICIA.
CONGRATULATIONS.
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
>> THANK YOU.
>> YOU'RE WELCOME.
DIANA.
RENEE.
CONGRATULATIONS.
>> BRITTANY.
MISS CASSANDRA.
CONGRATULATIONS.
>> THANK YOU SO MUCH.
>> YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
>> THAT BAD CHICK DIONNE.
>> OH, YEAH!
>> JAEL!
>> TYRA, I GET TO COME, TOO?
>> YOU GET TO COME, TOO.
>> WHITNEY, MEAN GIRL.
WORK IT OUT!
CONGRATULATIONS.
>> THANK YOU.
>> THE NEXT NAME
I'M GOING TO CALL...
SARAH.
CONGRATULATIONS.
>> THANK YOU.
>> WILL SAMANTHA AND NATASHA
PLEASE STEP FORWARD?
I ONLY HAVE ONE PHOTO
IN MY HANDS,
AND THIS PHOTO REPRESENTS
THE GIRL THAT WILL
STILL BE IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL,
AND I'LL CALL ONLY ONE NAME.
THE GIRL THAT I DO NOT CALL
MUST IMMEDIATELY
GO BACK TO THE HOUSE,
PACK HER BAGS
AND THEN GO HOME.
THE JUDGES SAY THAT YOU TWO
HAVE THE STRONGEST FACES,
BUT THERE'S DIFFERENT THINGS
THAT ARE LACKING.
SAMANTHA,
YOU TAKE BEAUTIFUL PICTURES.
BUT A LOT OF THE JUDGES
LOOK AT YOU AND SAY,
"SHE SEEMS 15,
AND MAYBE IN THREE YEARS
SHE'LL BE READY
FOR 'AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.'"
AND THEY LOOK AT YOU, NATASHA,
AND THEY SEE THIS GORGEOUS FACE,
BUT FOR SOME REASON
CAN'T TRANSLATE THAT TO A PHOTO.
SO THEY THINK,
IS SHE PHOTOGENIC
OR JUST A BEAUTIFUL GIRL?
SO WHO GOES HOME?
THE GIRL
WITH THE BEAUTIFUL PICTURES,
WHERE THE PERSONALITY
SEEMS TO BE STUNTED
AND MAYBE SHE'S JUST
A LITTLE TOO GREEN,
OR THE GIRL
WITH THE STUNNING FACE
THAT CAN'T SEEM TO PUT THAT
ONTO FILM?
NATASHA.
>> OH, MY GOD. OH!
>> YOU TWO ARE BOTH BEAUTIFUL.
BUT WHAT BEAT OUT SOMEBODY
THAT TAKES BEAUTIFUL PICTURES
IS SOMETHING ON THE INSIDE
THAT THE JUDGES FEEL.
THEY FEEL THE STORY,
THEY FEEL A LIFE,
THEY FEEL EXPERIENCE,
AND THEY SEE BEAUTY
ON THE INSIDE, TOO.
AND THAT'S WHAT I LOVE
ABOUT THIS COMPETITION, 'CAUSE
IT'S NOT JUST ABOUT PRETTY
OR A PRETTY PICTURE.
IT'S ABOUT MORE THAN THAT.
CONGRATULATIONS.
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
COME HERE.
I THINK YOU JUST
NEED A LITTLE BIT MORE TIME.
A LITTLE BIT MORE TIME, OKAY?
>> (whispers) I LOVE YOU.
BE A GOOD GIRL, OKAY?
>> I'M NOT VERY OUTGOING.
I'M NOT WILD AND CRAZY JAEL.
THAT'S NOT ME.
I'M VERY SIMPLE.
YOU KNOW, THAT'S THE WAY
I WAS RAISED.
BUT I GET TO GO HOME
BACK TO MY FAMILY,
AND, YOU KNOW,
THAT'S THE PLUS SIDE
TO THE WHOLE THING.
AND, YOU KNOW, MAYBE LATER
THIS MODELING THING
WILL WORK OUT,
BUT IT JUST WASN'T THE TIME,
AND GOD HAS A PLAN FOR ME,
AND THIS WASN'T IT.
♪ ♪ ♪
>> COMING UP
ON "AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL,"
I GET A MAKEOVER SHOCKER
OF MY OWN.
AAH!
>> (screaming)
>> TEMPERS FLARE
BETWEEN RENEE AND BRITTANY.
>> YOU SURE DO ACT LIKE
YOU'RE STILL IN HIGH SCHOOL.
>> I'M STILL KICKING YOUR ASS
IN THIS COMPETITION.
>> AND JAEL GETS
SOME TRAGIC NEWS FROM HOME.
>> OH, NO!